hi i'm aisha curry and today we will be
making a delicious pan seared steak
along with some roasted veggies what i
love about the brussels sprouts recipe
is that we're mixing in that sweet and
savory aspect so we have our green from
the brussels sprouts we have the
delicious sweetness from the pear and
the honey and then a little tartness
from the cranberry it is to die for this
flavor combination is perfect for the
fall it's hearty pears are ready to go
and fresh and readily available it's a
nice way to combine two totally
different things and bring them into one
world i feel like this is a great recipe
for all of the tasty audience to make
because it's so easy and it's foolproof
but still packs all of that flavor that
we all want it's just one of the best
recipes potatoes an american staple but
we're brightening them up with a little
bit of lime and some herbs i feel like
it's a nice way to switch up your
traditional mashed potato or roasted
potato because we're adding in that
brightness it's going to be delicious
with my herbs i always shuck them off of
the stem it's the perfect way to get
everything off and not waste any of your
ingredients and the thing that a lot of
people don't realize is that they glide
easily off of that stem i feel like they
were made to do that i would make this
dish any time of year it's one of those
dishes that is super easy doesn't take a
lot of time but can still please a crowd
if you're having a dinner party or some
friends and family over it's just one of
those staple recipes so my pan steaks so
growing up we didn't necessarily have
filet or rib eye we often times did a
lot of skirt steaks my mom would cook
that in a pan and i loved the golden
brown crust that the steaks would get
and so i love to start it out on the
stovetop to get that perfect steakhouse
sear i feel like it allows the salt to
crisp up and to give the steak a nice
crust and then we finish it off in the
oven because that's going to give us the
most even heat to make sure that our
steaks are cooked perfectly through
the reason why i love food so much is
how it brings people together everybody
can relate to food we all need to eat
any place in the world you go to people
gather whether it's around the table in
a circle on the floor like you name it
and i think it's such a beautiful thing
and such a beautiful message today's
world we're eating out so much that i
want to keep that traditional live of
cooking at home and getting your friends
and family together and having that
sense of community and camaraderie and
togetherness
it's so good oh yes
[Music]
you